[Musik]
das ist eine eiche eichen sind zentral
für die walpurgisnacht
herzlich willkommen zur sternstunde
religion
schön dass sie dabei sind ja die
walpurgisnacht das ist die nach die auf
den ersten mai gefeiert
auch hier in gränichen im kanton aargau
hier bin ich zu besuch bei wika meyer
springen sie ist eine moderne hexe frau
maja springen sie bezeichnen sich als
moderne hexe das ist ein ziemliches
reizwort guten tage ist man herzlich
willkommen im wald ein ja das ist so
also das wort hexe polarisiert heute
immer noch sehr
aber es gibt einen großen unterschied
zwischen der hexe vom mittelalter und
der modernen hexe was ist denn der
unterschied in etwa ja das bild für das
hat sehr viel mit dem teufel zu tun
gehabt mit umweltkatastrophen mit
krankheiten und seuchen die man den
hexen zu schieben wollte weil man sonst
keine natürliche erklärung dafür hatte
moderne hexen die wählen das bewusst aus
lebensweg oder aus lebenseinstellung und
was machen sie jetzt hier genau das hat
auch mit ihrem lebensvollzug als hexe zu
tun
das gibt ein feuer für die
walpurgisnacht und also so wie wir so
ein bild an das alte keltische wort und
bell ist ein feuer gott und darum ein
kleines feuer ihm zu ehren
die walpurgisnacht ist eines der
bekanntesten haxton feste wahrscheinlich
auch aus denn sagen und dem märchen es
ist ein fest der freude des tanzes des
feuers es ist aber auch ein mondfest die
verein vier mond feste und für sonnen
feste und das ist eines der
also sie als hexen meinen wir aus
moderne hexen ja genau erfahren dass die
acht jahreskreis feste und die war wohl
gedacht oder eben welten ist eines davon
und ist ein fröhliches fest ein
ausgelassenes fest ist der beginn des
sommers die vereinigung des wald gottes
mit der maikönigin was ist das genau
also der wald gott und die main-klinik
was muss ich mir darunter vorstellen
also alle feste sind mit der natur
verbunden man bei auch beobachtet die
natur und früher hat man geglaubt dass
der sommer beginnen kann und die fälle
fruchtbar werden und die bäume und
blumen sprießen dass sich der herr des
waldes der die blätter grün macht der
über die wilden tiere herrscht über die
hirsche die rehe und die wildschweine
sich mit einer schönen maikönigin
vermählt es ist dann verantwortlich für
die fruchtbarkeit der felder für die
ernte für die bäume für die kirchen und
all die früchte die sich dann durch den
sommer entwickeln dass die zwei sich
vermählen
und das immer so beginnt aber das heißt
sie feiern
bild oder walpurgisnacht um diese
fruchtbarkeit hervorzurufen oder wie
muss ich mir das vorstellen genau und
wir feiern das leben weil immer einem
jahresfest gegenüber liegt ein anderes
fest und das wäre in diesem fall jetzt
sah ruin oder halloween das totenfest
dir also jetzt von mir das leben die
fruchtbarkeit und gegenüberliegenden
ende oktober feiern wir das alles ist
und was ich noch nicht versteht weswegen
wird das eigentlich nach einer
christlichen heiligen benannt also
walpurga ja es ist so das hat viele
dieser brauchtümer dieser natur fest die
sich gerade auf die ernte beziehen
und mit der landwirtschaft zu tun haben
den leuten schwer auszutreiben waren und
man wollte nicht unbedingt mehr diesen
bäll also diesen feuergott eben
verlieren oder überhaupt im namen haben
also hat man sich auf diese walburga auf
die heilige walburga eine äbtissin
berufen und hat das eigentlich jahr für
christianisiert und so war es dann
eigentlich okay also man durch für das
weiter feiern solange keiner der in den
unteren decker ja genau unter dem neuen
namen allerheiligen jetzt man hört es
schon sie forschen schon seit 30 jahren
zu hexen sie haben ja auch selber ein
hexenmuseum gegründet schauen wir uns
das doch mal sehr gerne kommen sie mit
[Musik]
aber das schaut jetzt wirklich aus
während seiner starb es ist auch ein
zauberstab und ist auch ein zepter
rezepte der hohepriesterin was was man
das genau das ist eine ausbildung die
man früher noch machte wenn man das
wirklich erlernen wollte das hexen
handwerk von grund auf also eine
wirkliche hexen ausbildung wirkliche
hexen aus klären und die geht bis zum
dritten grad und als das wäre dann das
zepter und die krone die man erhält und
haben das eine hexen so ein zepter
nein nicht mehr also das war früher
eigentlich die tradition dass man sich
so richtig zur hexe aus werden lässt
heute ist das sehr offen und frei
man kann sich selber fixe nennen man
kann bücher lesen und beziehen im
internet das ist nicht mehr und eine
geweihte hexe ist nicht unbedingt nötig
aber haben sie denn so was wie einen
gemeinsamen glauben
der glaube ist auch sehr frei das ist
eigentlich das schöne daran dass man das
machen kann was man möchte oder das
glauben kann was man möchte und
übernimmt in diesem sinn die
selbstverantwortung und die einen
glauben an eine göttin an einen gott und
die anderen wieder nicht dass es ist ein
gibt keine vorschrift
diese ist das denn eine religion also im
weitesten sinn ist es eine naturreligion
man glaubt an die kraft der elemente
dass bäume beseelt sind die pflanzen
beseelt sind das die modi in der mond
die göttin ist und die sonne
der gott quasi das ist dann wäre das
dann eigentlich das männliche und das
weibliche pendant andere glauben an eine
universelle kraft die über alles
herrscht da gibt es keine frau kein
manske keinen namen für das göttliche es
ist einfach das gute das universelle das
über bewusstsein
aber es gibt schon mehr hexen
weidlich als männlicher ich denke ja es
gibt auch keine meldet zentral aber ich
würde mal mit 5.000 schweizer hexen die
ich jetzt vermuten kann rechnen
und da ist sicher 70 prozent sind frauen
und 30 prozent mehr was ich ganz
interessant finde was man immer wieder
auch liest bei hexen modernen hexen dass
es diese stärke und diese selbstbewusste
frau betont werden dass hexenturm früher
auch so was wie eine frauenbewegung ja
das ist es auch heute zum teil noch weil
hat das etwas ist was den frauen gehört
also in die eigene kraft kommen als hexe
darfst du stark sein als hexe darfst du
suchst du deine kraft seine qualitäten
du arbeitest dass diese auch aus und für
viele ist dann kein platz für einen mann
aber eigentlich ist in der hexerei die
dualität die polarität sehr wichtig als
das braucht das männliche wie das
weibliche prinzip aber da haben sie auch
zweiter dann genau das was wir gesagt
haben und es ist einfach so dass eine
starke frau auch einen mann erträgt aber
jede seite bin ich also es ist eine
schließt das andere ja und was mich
jetzt abschließend schon noch
interessieren würde
sie bezeichnen sich öffentlich als hexe
was lockt das für leute an
also es ist eigentlich ihr nicht
unbedingt die neugier der menschen aus
einer hexe ist das kann man sich
irgendwo auch informativ an lesen oder
oder die informationen beschaffen es
gibt aber viele menschen die hoffen dass
man ihnen helfen kann also in bei
problemen in liebesdingen in
gesundheitlichen dingen und das ist dann
halt das was was was man sich erhofft
ein bisschen die unterstützung auf einer
höheren übernatürlichem aber das kann
ich leider nicht bieten also ich kann
vielleicht ein tipp geben wie man sich
selbst helfen kann weil am schluss muss
man sich selber helfen sondern sucht
sich die hilfe der hexe
[Musik]
das buch hier ist der matthäus
magnifique arum der sogenannte
hexenhammer sowas wie die bibel der
hexenverfolgung der dominikaner
mechanisches kramer schrieb darin 1486
folgendes also schlecht ist das weib von
natur das schneller am glauben zweifelt
auch schneller dem glauben abschwört als
die grundlage von hexerei ist
ich frage mich hier schon frau meier
springen was wird dafür ein frauen bild
gezeichnet
jack ein sehr positives die zeit wo das
buch entstanden ist ist schon nicht
unbedingt die hohe zeit der frauen also
die frau im manne untertan sie war
ungültig und man bezeichnete auch den
ursprung des wortes femina was die
weiblichkeit bezeichnet die von fidesz
glaube und mina weniger dass unser
kramer macht das auch dass genau das
auch die frauen sind weniger gläubiger
und begründet das dann auch dass die
frau darum eben auch schlechter dasteht
oder sei es ist den leuten aber oft auch
gar nicht bewusst dass die kirche
eigentlich bis ins 13
jahrhundert hexen verleugnet hat und
hexen glauben als heidentum abgetan hat
deswegen gab es diesen wandel wo dann
dieser hätte diese hexen hysterien stand
ja es waren verschiedene ereignisse die
man erklären wollte die man erklären zu
erklären versuchte aber der haupt- oder
mit ein hauptauslöser war schon die
erscheinung des marius manificat weil
man zum ersten mal ein regelwerk hatte
was ist eine hexe wie erkennt man eine
hexe wie folgt man sie immer wie wird
man sie wieder los und durch dieses werk
nicht des dominikaners kam natürlich
auch die inquisition und zu kramer waren
inquisitoren so wurde die verfolgung der
hexen also das waren auch männer nicht
nur frauen aber die wende kam später vor
allem dann eben mit mit dem buch also
ich ganz spezifisch auch aufgefallen es
ist dieser stark verbreitete magie
glaube in dieser
zeit was hat es damit auf sich ja der
volksglauben oder der magie glauben ich
habe hier ein stück erste ausstellung
ein exponat hier sieht man wie man
gedacht hat oder wie man versucht hat
gewisse zauber von sich fernzuhalten
es ist ein so genanntes charivari das
kennt man noch aus der basler fasnacht
oder aus der tracht und das auch
getragen dass wurde getragen von den
männern vor dem hosenstall also das ist
kein collier und man wollte so
eigentlich eine der bösesten zauber
abwenden gegen die potenz des mannes und
man glaubte dann mit den krallen mit dem
gebiss wäre das abgewehrt werden dass
zerfetzt und das bock des judas beck
also das hören des jungen boxer sie ja
genau das soll dann die potenz wieder
stärken und steigen also die leute
hatten keine versicherungen sie mussten
sich irgendwie schützen vor dem
ungeheuren was da in der welt passierte
und so nahmen sich solche sachen und die
hexe hat es ganz spezifisch auf die
männliche potenz abgesehen das war
natürlich die urangst also natürlich
waren die für viele schon alles was man
sich nicht erklären konnte oder wollte
waren die hexen wunderbare sind ganz
spezifisch sieht man ja auch in den
anklagen dass man die hexen mit frost
und dem ganzen ernteausfall in einem
zusammenhang brachte also gab es da
einen klaren zusammenhang zwischen
klimawandel und hexen waren ja man sieht
dass es eine steigerung der
hexenverfolgung gab oder der
hinrichtungen
immer wenn irgendetwas passiert ist in
der natur was nicht erklärbar war diese
kleine eiszeit von 15 70 die 16 30 die
sie angesprochen haben
das war für die menschen unerklärlich da
fehlt mir das verständnis für die
naturwissenschaft an der seite auch die
pest oder krankheiten die da kommen und
unheimlich viele menschen dahinraffte
lässt unerklärlich wie sie kommt wie sie
entsteht wer angesteckt wird wer nicht
und so hat man immer irgendwie
irgendetwas einen sündenbock gesucht hat
man versuchte das zu erklären und sagte
ja was geht mit dem teufel zu und der
ton verbraucht verbündete und da bietet
sich ja wieder die frau an mit der sich
verbündet und die erhalten dann vom
käufer die puppe fürs wetter machen oder
sie halten die magische kraft und um
andere dinge zu verursachen
jetzt fällt dir die zeit der
hexenverfolgung auch in die zeit des
dreißigjährigen krieges in die zeit der
reformation als er die reformation für
einen einfluss auf den hexen waren die
reformation hat einen großen einfluss
dass es gab gleich nochmals einen
aufschwung in der hexenverfolgung weil
diese aufspaltung der kirche hat den
menschen die grundfesten entzogen
für viele ist und war der glaube eine
stabile grundlage im leben und wenn sich
die kirche aufspaltet wenn man sich
nicht mehr einig ist wenn man plötzlich
alles was man geglaubt hat ist plötzlich
ketzerei dann mussten die menschen nicht
mehr was sie noch glauben und und was
gilt jetzt überhaupt noch
und auch da hat man wieder gesagt das
geht mit dem teufel zu uns dass da
suchte man wieder eine ursache dafür in
der schweiz ist der annabelle die
eigentlich als die bekannteste ex also
die letzte hexe die in europa
hingerichtet wurde
sie haben aber im museum und sowieso in
ihrer ganzen forschung statt archive
durch gesucht um die namen der hexen die
in der schweiz verurteilt wurden
darzulegen was es ab worauf sind sie
dann gekommen die jetzt 19 hat das ganze
angefangen mit dem ersten hexenprozess
das heißt fast 350 jahre haben die hexen
verfolgt hingerichtet und die zauber der
ich jetzt ungefähr angekommen bin
steigt übersteigt die 10.000 ich bin
noch nicht fertig also für uns ist es
wichtig dass es nicht nur an geld
18 über 10.000 euro am meisten haben sie
es schon herausgefunden ja das gebiet
freiburg fribourg das wallis ist ein
gebiet das sehr sehr betroffen worden
also in der welt schweiz eigentlich
vielen dank frau mal springt für dieses
gespräch und für die gastfreundschaft
hier schloss ribbeck auch ich danke ihm
sehr herzlich vor allem vielen dank
jetzt gleich sehen sie den film
hexenjagd er zeichnet nach wie damals
aus braven bürgern mörder und folterer
wurden und wie daraus die hexen hysterie
entstand bleiben sie also dran und dann
einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]